Saturday's royal wedding ceremony
blended British tradition with some
American customs the Archbishop of
Canterbury declared Harry and Megan to
be married American Bishop Michael curry
delivered a rousing sermon you could say
there were musical performances by the
choir of st. George's Chapel and a group
of gospel singers from the London area
known as a kingdom choir vladimir
duthiers spoke with some of the group's
members after the ceremony the fact that
we were able to be a part of the day
even to be in this vicinity with them is
a blessing within itself but to share
what we think is was very dear to us as
singers and musicians and you know
vessels of message givers it's it
transcends beyond anything I can't
quantify I've said a lot of words I
can't truly pinpoint how this feels
mind-blowing mind-blowing is Right CBS
News contributor and author of the Diana
Chronicles Tina Brown was with us in
Windsor for the whole six hours and she
wasn't wearing comfy shoes at the table
she actually had on heels Tina I still
can't get over but let's offer that
quiet opera second the afterglow is huge
yeah because I met somebody from Prince
Charles's office who told me that it was
a Prince's idea that Prince Charles's
idea to get the gospel choir he
presented that to Harry and Megan I was
surprised he I just assumed that it was
Megan she said no it was Charles as I I
know it was a mind-blowing fact to learn
did you hear that - I did and but you
know Charles is just really an offbeat
and wonderfully said a progressive an
eclectic guy I mean he loves all kinds
of music it's really people don't
understand actually that Charles has
always been this very inclusive man and
somehow because he looks so Square and
everything yes you does look quite but
but he's never been stuffy actually I
mean almost things he loved you know
there's his whole environmental passions
you know organic food people mocked him
for it but of course he was right he was
ahead and you know he loves gospel music
and people just are blown away to hear
there's a couple seems they had to
though Tina they seemed ahead like
nothing there that anybody has seen
we've been saying that even before the
wedding but certainly after seeing that
wedding and seeing the way people the
way
we'll cheered and were so tears of joy
literally in the streets of Windsor it
really was an amazing uplift to be there
I mean you and I was standing there and
somehow when that carriage came out and
so close to us as it came around the
corner you saw the intimacy of Windsor -
that's what one of the things that made
it so joyful it was such a a small town
really and people were so close and it
all felt so emotional much more emotion
in this wedding than I've ever seen in
any royal wedding mhm
it was it was beautiful and symbolic I
thought the titles given to the couple
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex there our
nod to Prince Augustus Frederick who
supported the abolition of the slave
trade and civil rights who chose those
idols well the Queen you know has a kind
of repertoire of titles that you can
give out and really there's a that's a
great number right now of royal Dukes
and Sons and cousins and so on so she
actually needs to go into that closet
heraldic closing and get out of title
that she can use so partly was about the
fact that it was available but I'm sure
that there was a delight that that was
part of his pedigree speaking of delight
what happened after at the party after
with the speeches and the dancing well
Prince Charles you ever want to worry
apparently with a very very moving
speech at the reception at lunch where
he actually recalls giving Harry a
bottle when he was a tiny baby and
changing his his diaper and called him
darling old Harry I was such a sweet
thing and I think you've seen a lot more
emotion from all of the royal family
this was a most loved up wedding that I
can remember with the Royals you know
there was such a fierce passion between
these two people and you knew you even
saw Princess Anne's daughter Zara
Tyndall her husband was patting her her
baby bulge and there was love and there
was Charles calling him darling old
Harry I mean this is not the usual royal
wedding no yeah it really did not just
tremble it's just like if it was bloody
robbery yes I heard people didn't know
that the Royals really didn't quite know
what to make of Reverend Currie
I saw somebody from from who knows the
royal family very well they said listen
the Queen would have seen what he was
going to say but she would not have
known that he was going to deliver it
that way it's Saturday Night Live said
it's like a chicken and waffle kiosk in
a pottery barn
people are like what in the world is
this but I think they liked it I think
you know I actually heard that everybody
just thought it wrong do you know that
they loved it and it just brought that
energy into that church and then when
you followed it with the Gospel Choir
it was like this is a happening marriage
he wasn't having happening there amazing
message too because he was focused sure
on the love of the couple but then he
turned it around to the rest of the
world and said love brought us here but
bring this love back out into the world
that was it was actually beautiful I
thought it was a complete hit and
clearly you know he had 40,000 partly
40,000 tweets a minute we're going on
but it all goes down to the love though
Tina I still will never forget Prince
Harry
looking at her saying you look amazing
I'm so there's something about the word
amazing not beautiful you look amazing
and I'm so lucky it's the look between
the two of them that I will always
remember that a lot of people resonate
with but resonate with a lot of the
adoration in her face where he takes off
the veil and there's this between them
there is just this extraordinary
chemistry that yeah we really asked but
you guys did an amazing I'm you really
doing it was a pretty amazing yeah six
hours six hours flew by and that cake
Thank You Tina
[Laughter]